more nutrition truths that Wellness
influencers don't want you to know
lettuce water won't help you sleep it's
literally just water boiled in water a
hot girl walk is literally just a walk
shot from the neck down you don't have
to get protein in immediately after your
workout so
stop dry scooping your protein as you
leave the gym
just because you bought it at Whole
Foods does make it a whole food vegans
of vegetarians can easily meet their
nutrient needs so stop writing them
about protein the 10 000 step a day rule
was actually a marketing tool not an
evidence-based suggestion
if you've got a bikini and a body
congratulations you've got a bikini body
eating six meals a day won't boost your
metabolism and eating once a day won't
make you automatically burn fat which of
these nutrition treats are going to make
the most influencers mad